hey guys it's the first Monday of July
the month where Jeff Goldblum and Will
Smith save us from an alien menace
what's your favorite Jeff Goldblum film
and if it's the fly you're making your
best friends
sings you down in that comment section
thank you so much for leaving your
comments including the one about Dan
maybe maybe not looking like a french
fry and why I stray from side to side
when I present I don't know why I do it
either but for now here's gamespot news
first up five nights at freddy's 6 was
an out sweep and then can't belt no yeah
there's a lot to unpack here five nice
grade to scott cawthon revealed that
there was to be a sixth entry in the
popular horror series about animatronic
murder bears but maybe not anymore in a
statement posted on Steam Coughlin's
explained that the pressure had become
way too much explaining after forcing
myself to keep working on a day after
day I realized something I just don't
want to work on this with each game's
release I think the expectations get
higher and higher for the next and
rightfully so but that pressure starts
to mount and I fear that I've been
neglecting other things in my life for
the sake of trying to keep up with those
mounting expectations he concluded that
he won't be working on the sixth
installment anymore but that doesn't
mean he's leaving game development or
abandoning the series altogether Coulson
is asked for respect and understanding
regarding his decision and added he
hopes to create avianna title and that
the five nights movie is in amazing
hands with bluem house productions a
games world size in its play time are a
much discussed topic these days but
personally I don't really care too much
about those kind of details that's right
Dan
size doesn't matter but for those of you
who do care the creative director of
Assassin's Creed origins has come out to
explain how big the game is a chef is
melt old Game Informer that it's
difficult to compare past games since
every project is different but that
Assassin's Creed origins is much bigger
than black flag saying I would say that
it's at least twice the size of Havana
from Black Flag at least he also added
that he doesn't think the site is
important however saying it's really the
content the experience that you've had
inside of it
it's how alive it is so we filled those
locations with quests with making each
city feel unique to itself why was it
important to Egypt
elsewhere in the interview Ishmael said
that the game map is open pretty much
right after the introductory sequence so
you can judge for yourself
he also teased that the modern-day
elements of our
are being mostly kept secret so players
will be surprised and that there will be
customization options Assassin's Creed
origins is out October 27 this year
finally players of GTA online have found
proof of alien life a sort of clues to a
secret alien mission were included in
June's gun running update and models
have since uncovered the mission and
found a way to play us gataki reported
that the updates code suggested that
there might be a UFO crash site near the
Zancudo military base modding group team
guru took that to heart and managed to
unlock the mission although there's a
fair chance it's not in its finished
state you can watch the whole thing in
their YouTube video but essentially
here's how it goes
crash site revealed dead scientists
Playa picks up alien egg kills angry
aliens and the mission ends with
delivering the egg to a bunker rockstar
have yet to make any mention of the
mission so don't feel like you're
missing out by not playing it right away
as a likely surface later on let us know
if you think there's an alien themed GTA
online update in our future or not in
that comment box that is everything
we've got for you today thanks so much
for joining us once again and if you've
ever wanted to be as famous as Jessica
McDonald and I we've never been referred
to as famous no one even knows who we
are
leave a comment in that comment section
telling me what the best Jeff Goldblum
movie is and I will read it out for you
tomorrow
see you then